[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in one of my last videos i discussed the
origins of dementors
and the story of a dark and evil wizard
named a christmas
but in that same video i also scratched
the surface
of another story the story of an evil
wizard
known as rexidian roxidian was a dark
who was said to have existed during an
unknown period in time
is only referred to as ancient there is
a case for the argument
that rexitian is the father of dementis
as he may have existed
before christus and in the ancient tales
that speak of him
dementors are mentioned he was a very
talented dark wizard
who was fully immersed in the dark arts
able to produce all sorts of evil
concoctions
and cast all sorts of sinister spells
but one thing that he always had trouble
with
was what we now know to be the patronus
charm a patronus charm is produced when
a witcher wizard casts the spell
expecto patronum there are two types of
patronus charms
corporeal and incorporeal and the type
that the witch or wizard casts
will depend on their experience or
preference
the more basic form of the spell is the
incorporeal patronus
which assumes no animal form and simply
resembles a burst of white vapour or
smoke
and the more advanced form of the spell
is the conjuring
of a corporeal patronus the ability to
successfully cast a corporeal patronus
is considered a very impressive feat in
the wizarding community
the corporeal patronus assumes the form
of the witch or wizards
spirit animal and varies extensively
from which to which
or wizard to wizard harry's is a stag
hermione's is an otter
etc it's also worth mentioning that
there's no way to know
what your patronus is until you cast it
professor catalyst spangle explains this
no reliable system for predicting the
form of an individual's patronus
has ever been found however it's also
been expressed that a patronus
can change the form of a patronus may
change during the course of a witch or
wizard's life
instances have been known of the form of
the patronus transforming
due to bereavement falling in love or
profound
shifts in a person's character while
casting spells that create your very own
spirit animal is impressive there is a
purpose
and that purpose is to ward off
dementors or lethal folds
dark creatures that feed on human
happiness and incite a feeling of
despair
and anyone that gets close to them they
are among the foulest creatures around
and represent nothing but darkness
depression
and decay they are also notably
difficult to get rid of
and the only known way that it can be
done is with a patronus
this is because the patronus represents
everything that dementor doesn't
hope happiness survival and purity
as the patronus itself does not feel
despair or hopelessness
as a human might the dementors can't
hurt it
and are repelled by its presence but you
might now be asking
if rexidian commanded dementors then why
would he need to cast a patronus charm
to dig into this further we need to look
at the story of elias
a young orphan wizard who saved his
village from the dark wizard
rexidian alias came from a small
wizarding village in the mountains
and reciding lived in a black castle in
a nearby forest
guarded entirely by dementors knowing
that dementors roamed the forest
the villagers took care to teach every
new generation
the patronus charm the only spell that
worked against these evil creatures
many were unable to master the difficult
spell but there had always been just
enough patronuses in the village
to stand guard against the dementors in
case rexidian ordered an attack
when elias turned 17 the village elders
taught him
and his fellow young wizards the spell
ilius
who was shy and tongue-tied succeeded in
producing a patronus
but to his shame it took the form of a
mouse
everyone roared with laughter because
they had never seen such a small
weak patronus and the eldest advised the
boy
never to use the spell again the
townspeople had a fairly harmonious
relationship with the rexidian
they didn't quite get along with him or
fraternize with him
but they left each other alone however
that all began to change
when ricksidian saw a girl from the
village named
eliana rexidian took notice of eliana
a beautiful young girl who lived in the
village who ilius had never spoken to
due to his shyness while she was out
picking berries in the forest
deciding that she would make an ideal
wife raccidian sent a demand to her
parents
but they refused to consent to the
marriage brookside then threatened to
send his dementors to destroy the
village
unless they delivered eliana to him the
village elders had a meeting
and agreed to put up a fight eliana was
sent to elias's tiny shack
and elias was ordered to sit out the
battle and keep her company
as his patronus was thought to be too
weak to be of any use
at first the villagers managed to hold
back the torrent of dementors
that attacked the village with their
patronuses which included bears
wolves and wild boars but gradually
the sheer number of foes began to
overwhelm them the patronuses grew faint
and the spellcasters collapsed or fled
for their lives
eliana begged ilyas to do something so
he cast the patronus charm
and despite its diminutive size the
mouse shone with a brilliant light
bringing the dementors to a halt as it
nimbly moved through the ranks of
fleeing villages
elias who was thought previously
unimpressive due to his patronus animal
form of
a mouse suddenly became the town's
saving grace
however when rexidian saw that his
dementors were being bested
he decided to take things into his own
hands enraged
riccidian decided to enter the fray
himself and tried to summon a patronus
to ward off elias's mouse however he
failed to remember that only the pure of
heart
can produce a patronus and thus for the
first time in history
it was revealed what happens when a
competent but unworthy wizard or witch
attempts the spell maggots shot out of
ricksidian's wand
and quickly devoured him as they
engulfed his entire body
as we can clearly see rexidian who was
massively magically talented
was simply not able to produce the
patronus charm properly
because he was not pure of heart why he
even attempted to cast it in the first
place
is a little unclear as he was not faced
with dementors
he seemed to cast it because he wanted
to ward off elias's mouse patronus
but i don't think it can be used for
that he simply didn't understand what
the spell represented
and he was unable to understand because
he was a dark and
evil wizard where a normal witch or
wizard could expect to be introduced to
their spirit animal when casting the
spell for the first time
rexidian was met with maggots not only
that
but they were maggots that devoured him
engulfing his body
on this fateful day brexitian said the
precedent
for what will happen if you try to
produce a patronus when you are
emotionally and ethically unable
this is the same reason that many
infamous dark witches and wizards
don't know how to produce one voldemort
bellatrix and dolorhov
none of them could do it no matter how
talented they were
however one thing that i'm curious about
is whether or not maggots were unique to
rexidian
if another dark witch or wizard tried to
produce the same spell
would they be met with maggots as well
or would they be on the receiving end of
some other
unfavorable result it's hard to say
because
understandably no other witch or wizard
in history
attempted it after him he had made it
very clear
if you're evil you can't do it i like to
imagine that maggots
were unique to obsidian it was a true
representation
of the type of person that he was and
that's it for this video
what's your patronus animal let me know
down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
harry
you